[موسيقى]
لطالما طمحت مريم المنصوري لاختراق السحاب
منذ صغرها وظنت ان حلمها لن يتحقق الى ان
اصبحت اول طيار حربي في سلاح الجو
الاماراتي وبمرتب
رائد قررت ان اصبح طيارا حربيا بعد ان
انهيت الثانويه العامه لكن المجال لم يكن
مفتوحا امامي لاصبح طياره حربيه لذا
اضطررت لان انتظر ما يقارب ع اعوام انه
شعور رائع بان تكون لديك الثقه الكافيه
لقياده هذه المركبه الثمينه والقيمه
لتتمكني من الطيران بها لوحدك والدفاع عن
وطنك وتقول الرائد مريم ان المسؤولين
يدعمون بشده طموحاتها لكنها اعترفت بان
تجربتها الاولى اتسمت بالتردد ذاته الذي
تشهده الثقافه الشرقيه عند دخول النساء
مجال عمل مخصص للرجال لكنها تغلبت على ذلك
والان تؤمن بانها تغلبت على جميع الحواجز
ولكن هنالك ثقل في المسؤوليه على
عاتقها شعرت بانني حملت على عاتق هذه
المسؤوليه واثبتت بانه يمكنني ان اصبح
طياره مقاتله بنفس جداره اي رجل في هذا
الاسطول وتقول الرائد مريم انه لا يمكنها
ان تستثنى من القواعد عندما يتعلق الامر
بمجال عملها وتضيف بان الاوضاع في الشرق
الاوسط اوجبت على الجميع بان يكون متحضرا
يجب على كل مواطن في هذه البلد ان يكون
جاهزا للدفاع عن الامارات العربيه المتحده
لذا ليس من المهم ان كنت ذكرا ام انثى
طالما نحن متحضرون للدفاع عن
وطننا